So Brady my good friend,
Eric angiolini who lives in Brussels.
He came up with the following operation. This is an operation.
You can take a number and you can transform it. If you start off with 123,
if you look at the first two digits, it says 12,
you're allowed to have that divided by two,
and you would get 63 that's illegal operation,
take a sub number and divide it by two. If it's even,
or you could double the number,
you could also take the two and you could double it and you'd get 143,
or you could double the three and you get 126,
or you could double the 23 and you would get 146,
or you could double the world and you will get 223.
So those are examples of things you can do.
Let's take something like two Oh two, one eight.
There's a nice big number.
You can focus your attention on any sub number in there.
So for instance, if we look at that too, that's an even number.
We can divide it by two, and that would give us one Oh two, one eight,
and we have a choice. And that, in fact, I call this Schweider breasts.
It's Brussels choice because in honor of Aerie,
you could also take the two Oh two and divide it by two.
And you would get one Oh one, one eight, and you can do any sub string.
If it's even,
you can either divide it by two or double it in place. If it's odd,
you can just double it.
And you can choose that.
And it's completely arbitrary where you attack like that.
Yes, you're free to choose,
but you have a target because you're trying to get back down to one.
Uh, that's the game.
That's the game. Get to it, or conversely,
because this is a symmetric operation.
If you can go from X to Y you can equally well go from MITRE X.
Every these operations are reversible.
And what are we iterating here? Are we we're going in steps.
But I want to show you one more example here, because this is the surprise.
This is the joke from two Oh two, one eight.
If I pick that eight and double it,
we get two Oh two, one, one six.
That eight has become 16 in place.
I've keeping the two Oh two one,
but I'm doubling the eight and we get two Oh two, one, one six,
or I could take that 18 and divide it by two.
And we would get two Oh two nine.
And we've shortened the length by one digit.
It's not difficult to prove that if you start with a number and once you get by
this operation is at most 10 N and at least,
and over 10th,
you can find examples where it gets you arbitrarily close to end of a 10.
So there's a wide range of numbers. Okay. So let's let that rules with one step,
obviously that's with one step. Yes. And then the question is,
if you start off with a random number,
how long will it take to get to one? Is it even possible to always get to one?
Is it, Oh yeah. I want to know. Yes. Well, show me an example of getting to one.
Okay. Yes. Well,
so let me go the other way round and let's go from one and see what we can get
because it's symmetric, but one, we can go to two. In fact,
we can only go to two from two. We can go to four from four. We can go to eight.
From eight. We can go to 16. From 16. We can go to 112.
This is the crucial step.
We double that six and we get 112 from 112.
We can divide by two and go to 56. From 56.
We can divide by two and go to 28. From 28.
We can divide that eight by two and go to 24. Then bingo, 12,
six, three, three is hard to get to from one,
but you can do it. And it took one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11 steps to go from one to three.
And if you want to have some fun, figure out how to go from one to seven,
say or nine or 73.
Oh, you completely changed the game on me.
Then I thought this whole game was going to be about taking arbitrary numbers
and getting down to one. It is, but I'm reversing it now.
You've just built a new game where you go up, you go.
You start it. But these steps are reversible. Well, all right,
we start at three. How do we get to one? We double it. We get six.
Double it again. 12, double it again. We get 24 double the four 28.
Double it again. 5,600. And are now at 112.
We can divide that 12 by two and get six.
So it's goes to 16 and an eight four, two, one.
Can I give you any number? Can we always get to one? Yes.
So that's a very good question. And the answer is no.
Look at all the numbers in the world, all the positive images in the world,
there are two kinds, those that end in zero or five,
and they're all connected.
And those that don't end in zero or five and they're all connected.
So I can get from one to 73 and I can get from one to 74,
but I can't get from one to 10 or one to 90 or 95 because they end in a
five.
If the last digit was a zero or a five that doesn't change under
these operations.
So that we'll never get to one because it will always end with a zero or a five.
Yes. Okay.
And let me prove that you can always get to one,
if it doesn't end in a zero or a five, or I suppose that's not true.
Look at the smallest number that cannot get to one. Let's call it.
K K never gets to one,
no matter how clever we'd how hard we try and K doesn't end in zero off.
That's the claim. Suppose you could get from K to a smaller number,
then that would be a counterexample. Because if you get K to say,
L and L is less than K L would be a smaller number that you could not get to
one from because this, the operation reversible.
So every number that you can get from K must be bigger than K.
So that means look at the digits of K.
We can't have a six because we did we'd have it.
And we get a smaller number for UK. Yeah.
We didn't have that numb have the six digit and we get to three and that would
be smaller than K. So every digit of came must be odd. Okay.
And what's more, it can't be three.
There can't be a three digit in K,
because we could do this to it and get it down to one.
And that would be a smaller number.
This chain takes you from three to one.
This chain takes you from two to one. I didn't show you how to go from seven.
Okay. When we got to 28,
I could go to 14 by having the whole number and having it again to seven.
So seven via seven, 14, 28, 56,
seven goes to one. And what about nine? If I could do nine,
I will have done all the digits. Single digits, except five and zero and five.
And Sarah, you can't do, we can't handle them.
So how do I get to the nine? 18 would be good.
So from 14, I can double the floor and get 18.
I can have the 18 and get nine. So nine is connected to one.
So all the numbers between one and nine,
a joined to one except five and zero.
So K can't have a one, a two, a three or four. It could be.
It could have a one,
it could be all ones or it could have a five in the middle of it.
K could be maybe one, one, five, one.
That's so far. I haven't ruled that out because you can't get from five to one.
So all the digits of K are ones and fives. Okay.
So if there was a five in the interior of it, well,
it would have to be followed by a one from 51.
We can go to 52 double the one we can go to 26 and 26 is less than 51.
So we've got reached a smaller number.
So they could be followed by another five. Yes.
It did. But the last five must be followed by a one. So if this argument works,
just look at the right most five, and we get a smaller number. What about,
um, a number that's all once. K.
So the argument so far has shown that K must be all at once. Well,
all right. Look at the last two ones, double it,
make it a 12 of it, make it a six. So we've changed 11 to a six.
We've got a smaller number contradiction. So K does not exist.
So every number not ending in a zero or five can get to one.
And conversely, because these operations are symmetric,
we can go from one to any number, not ending in zero and five.
Now what about the other numbers? The numbers at the end do end in zero or five.
Well,
they they're all connected and that maybe I switched to red and show you that
we can get from 90 to 10 because whatever this number is,
we can get from one, one seven, nine, three, zero.
We can get to 10 proof.
This number doesn't end in zero or five. Well,
we can get to one from it. So we get to 10 and then two, five.
So the other class of numbers are all connected.
We use the first argument to get everything down to 10, but,
and never the Twain shall meet. There were two, two connected components. Okay.
So the question is, if you start with a big number,
how many steps is it going to take to get down to one assume, make it end.
It doesn't end in zero or five. There are two parts to that.
One is to look at what's the biggest number you can get from one in case steps.
And the answer is basically you can use the greedy algorithm in one step.
All we can do is go to two and two steps. All you can do is get two, four,
and then eight, and then 16 from 16, the biggest one,
two, three, four. The biggest thing you can get as a, 112 by doubling the six.
The rule is if you want to get the biggest number, you look for a digit,
which is bigger than five, and as far to the right as possible.
And you double that. If it's a six,
you go from that six all the way to the end and you double that string.
And that's the biggest child. The biggest number you can get in,
in that step from 16, it's pretty clear.
The best you can do is double the six in place. And we get one, one, two,
one 12, which we read, which is 112 will be, can do as double the whole number.
So we get two to four from two to four. All we can do is double it.
And we get four, four, eight. And when we double the eight, we get four, four,
one six, and now we've got a six. So we get four, four,
one, one, two. This is doing the greedy algorithm.
It's possible that we could get a bigger number by not being greedy,
but being more devious and taking us more Securitas route.
And after a certain number of steps,
getting a bigger number than we would get from this.
So now that there is no digit bigger than five,
so we just double it and we get eight, eight, two to four.
Finally, here we have digit. So the bigger than five.
And we look for the right, most, one of them, and that's the eight,
which is furthest to the right.
And we double the number starting at that eight all the way to the end.
So what we get is the eight one six four four eight. Now, again,
we have numbers that are six or higher, and we look for the right most one,
which is the final eight means we just double that eight in place.
And we get eight one six, four four one six,
the eight becomes a 16. We've lengthened the number by one digit,
and we've done it in the optimal way.
If we had doubled the number from the six onwards,
we'd get a smaller number because that six would become a 12 and the number
would begin eight one one by keeping the six and just
doubling the final eight. We used to keep the start eight one six.
So this is bigger than doing anything else. Let's keep going again.
We look for the right most digit, which is bigger than, or equal to six.
And that's six at the end. Again, we look for the right,
most digit that's six or higher.
And we double from there all the way to the end.
Again, look for the, the right most digit, which is six or more,
and that's this aid. So we double near to the end.
So that's going to give us, I want to keep eight one one two eight,
and now we double this and we get one six, four, four, eight, and in a minute,
we'll see a pattern. Let's go one more step.
We just double the eight and we get eight
+1 281644166 at the end, let's double that
(811) 281-6441.
The six becomes a 12. And now we can see the pattern.
That number is the same as this number. And then one, two, three,
four steps.
What has happened is we took that number and we put a prefix in front of it.
Eight one one two. Oh yeah. So from this point on,
there's a simple rule for the biggest number.
You can get using N steps starting at one,
and it grows by every four steps.
It grows by putting eight one, one two in front of it,
which is like multiplying it by adding four digits at the end.
If the number is bigger than this,
and we know we can't get to it by going in, by taking one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12. If the number is,
is bigger than this, we need more than 12 steps to get to it.
So this gives us a lower bound on how many steps we need to get to end.
We know that we can get down from skipping five.
We can.
Get from any digit one through nine,
we can get down to one and it must 11 steps.
You may remember that it took me 11 steps to get from one to three or from three
to one. So this is 11 steps.
In fact.
Any number between one and 99, not ending in zero or five,
gets down to one in at most 12 steps.
So if we start off with some huge number and we want to get to one,
we look at the first two digits and we apply at most 12 steps
and change the, whatever it is. We change it to a one.
I should also say that we can get from any number that ends in zero or
five. We can get down to five and at most 12 steps,
the same thing in short,
any two digit number we can reduce to adding one Oh
five and it was 12 steps. So say we have some huge number.
We want to get to one. We just whittle away.
We look at the top two digits and map them to either one or five.
And we repeat that. And each time we do that, it's taking,
it's costing us at most 12 steps. So roughly speaking,
12 times,
the number of digits in the number is an upper bound on how far we have,
how many steps we need to take to get down to one. Now, when I was younger,
I was taught not to play with matches like these,
but I think we can make an exception for today's episode sponsor. Brilliant,
and have a look at this. Can you see the fifth square in this arrangement?
Can you make four squares here by removing five matches?
These are just examples of the sorts of puzzles you're going to find on.
Brilliant. And there were loads of great courses, too.
Like the ones you're seeing on screen.
Now these are pretty elaborate courses with lots of steps to go through.
They're fun, interactive,
and elegantly designed by people who really know their stuff to find out more,
go to brilliant.org/number four,
where you can peruse all this stuff and using that slash number four.
We'll also line you up for 20% of brilliance, premium subscription,
which unlocks all the good stuff. And remember,
always be careful and thoughtful with matches real ones and mathematical
ones.